um you've been a part of like obviously
some pretty historical stuff in radio
um
you pretty much you did so I mean you
signed on real 92.3 in La which was a
very crazy thing to do at the time
because there is a Heritage station here
that
nobody would ever really think to [__]
with yep
um also you were very instrumental in uh
The Breakfast Club right I launched a
launch Power 105.1 so you launched
powerful 105.1 at the time when you
launched it it was Ed Lover in the
morning yep Ed and uh Dr Dre the other
Dr Dre yep the other one and then um we
went through a couple of iterations of
morning shows um
I think we uh Tigger was doing mornings
at one time then we had uh I think
before that it might have been uh star
and buck wild yeah how was that what
were those calls like
you know I tell everybody all the time
man like like he and I had a great
relationship man I like there was never
any malice between us he gave people a
hard time but I mean like me and him
were good man yeah like I remember he
and I having a conversation one time
about how many times he was gonna use
the n-word on his show because at this
time he was doing it like every two
seconds you say like hey you got five
percent no we I I vaguely remember the
conversation but I remember him
negotiating it down to 25. 25 times a
show 25 times uh an hour an hour show it
was it was Sun it was which is kind of
crazy because technically you couldn't
say it on the radio yeah technically you
can but it wasn't an Advertiser friendly
term for sure you might imagine and so I
remember bad for business to use it I
remember we he and I settled on that and
then um you know it progressively got
went back up to 40 and then you know
then those things
um ended crazy I don't ever want to take
credit for The Breakfast Club higher
because it was actually Cadillac Jack I
remember him calling me and telling me I
knew who Charlemagne was I knew who Envy
was because of what happened with star
um and I was aware who Angela was and at
the time the show started was the very
beginning of PPM
um early PPM early PPM measurement there
were a lot of misconceptions about PPM
measurement and the biggest problem was
that you should know if a show is a hit
within weeks also for people who don't
know what PPM is it's the it's a meter
that tells radio stations their ratings
exactly it's an imperfect system and
before that it used to be a diary so you
would get a diary correct you would
write down what you thought you listened
to versus what you actually listened to
much easier way to program it absolutely
much easier way so
um so the show started
um you know remember Cadillac and I
talking about it I thought um it was a
great idea
um but it didn't hit as quickly as
um people thought and we had done
something similar in Chicago with a
Morning Show and I remember that morning
show took a minute so
um after a few months when it didn't hit
I was called in for me in New York and
there was actually a thought of maybe
doing something different and um I
remember after a few months after a few
months okay because that was the
misconception at the time but I but
there was a chemistry between the three
that was like nothing I'd ever seen
right and um I remember being in a room
with them just kind of like you know
just we just talking and just like man
like if we could have a if this gets on
the radio and we give it time and we
promote it it's gonna be crazy I had no
idea would be what it became but yeah I
know you fielded calls for stuff I've
said before at least I know AOS about
artists have you ever had to deal with
blowback for like early Charlemagne
stuff where they're like yo
and I know you know before real you were
you obviously based in Jacksonville but
like you're at the I feel like you're
kind of the face of like yeah
who the industry talks to when it comes
to I heart [__] on the hip-hop side you
are that literally so was there ever any
like always always
um especially at the very early
different iterations of Charlemagne I
think early on he was he was wrong
and so um I get those complaints
obviously back in the day before uh
Charlemagne star was
it was routine man like NAACP would want
me to come like I'm not coming
like nah man like like if you took the
show locally I would always tell them
like you you took the show you know what
you got like you got to handle it like
I'm not flying across the country and
meeting with the you know United Negro
College Fund NAACP every city because of
every city that that was Affiliated
affiliated with the show because they
were hot you know um so but um but yeah
I mean they were there were there were
complaints it's part of the culture I
just I'm just wondering if like you know
you look at your phone and like it says
Diddy's calling right and then Diddy's
like yo yo doc
this is [__] by the way that's just
the name yeah yeah I mean it still
happens to this day yeah I mean I think
um some people think that that's what we
do we we set them up for the um you know
to get the clip on on social media which
I don't think you guys intentionally do
I think it just happens sometimes but
yeah but yeah get them a lot